three two one
once known as the final frontier space
could now become a tourist destination
for the rich and famous
endeavor so who are the key players
in this new space race
[Music]
the space race is nothing new after yuri
gagarin's first trip into orbit in 1961
space became a new battleground for the
cold war
but while the 20th century space race
was fueled by
geopolitical rivalry this new one is
something different
money
[Music]
well we can now see some live pictures
of sir richard branson who's just
launched
his first virgin galactic fully crewed
flight to the edges of space
on july the 11th 2021 sir richard
branson flew to the edge of space and
back
[Applause]
i was once a child with a dream looking
up to the stars
now i'm an adult in a spaceship virgin
galactic completed its first flight to
space
or technically an altitude of about 53
miles
but whether it is space proper or the
fringes of space
the vss unity launch was a big success
but it was also a victory for branson
over his closest space race rival
jeff bezos
amazon owner jeffrey bezos actually
announced his plans to go to space first
before being beaten to it by branson
and here the astronauts come
but on the 20th of july 2021 he blasted
off on blue origin's sub-orbital new
shepard rocket
and went to the edge of space himself
bezos picked the date because it was the
anniversary of neil armstrong and buzz
aldrin first stepping on the moon
but it isn't just bezos's famous love of
space that motivated him to go
blue origin are also entering the space
tourism business in the future
but if there was an early leader in the
billionaire space race
you'd have to give that to elon musk
crew 2
now making their way to the one and only
international space station
spacex already has a long and successful
history of space flight
they've sent astronauts to the
international space station and have
contracts with nasa
but musk seems less interested in space
tourism than his billionaire rivals
he has though spoken of his desire to
build a colony on mars
once saying he wanted to send humans to
the red planet by 2025
but musk isn't completely out of the
space tourism game with
rumors he's one of the 600 who've booked
a seat to space
with virgin galactic
[Music]
branson says space tourism will open
space to humankind and change the world
for good
if of course you have a spare quarter of
a million you're happy to part with
and bezos like musk has dreams of
building colonies for trillions of
people in space
now it's the sudden possibility of
everyday people going into space
at the moment it's very rich everyday
people but i think that will translate
to more and more of us in the future
grand plans but some critics have
pointed out that the earth these
billionaires are so keen on leaving
there's plenty more pressing problems to
sort out
so for some people it's hard to see this
billionaire space race as being anything
other
than an ego driven competition between
very rich men
but it should at least be fun to watch